[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et l'invité politique cette
semaine c'est Thomas porte bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis d'actualité pour vous
et elle a une cette semaine le Parlement
et la nation sous le choc après
l'attaque au couteau jeudi à Annecy qui
a notamment visé plusieurs enfants jeudi
elle est députée ont observé une minute
de silence
c'en est fini de la proposition de loi
du groupe liotte à l'Assemblée nationale
qui prévoyait d'abroger la retraite à 64
ans après quelques heures de discussions
je dis le texte a été retiré par les
députés lyode qui reprochaient à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a une brune pivée de cette opposée à un
vote sur ce texte les députés vont voter
désormais en début de semaine sur une
motion de censure du gouvernement et
puis les taux de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur le fond Marianne se
resserre autour de Marlène Schiappa elle
est sénateur s'interroge sur le rôle
réel de la ministre dans le pilotage de
ce fonds publics sont ces lutter contre
la radicalisation un rapport
administratif dénonce de graves
dysfonctionnements le préf et en charge
du projet a démissionner
d'abord le recueillement et les
questions après le drame effroyable
d'Annecy ou de très jeunes enfants ont
été attaqués au couteau Thomas portes
vous étiez en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale quand vous avez appris la
nouvelle qu'est-ce que qu'elle doit être
la réponse tout simplement dans ces
moments-là je crois que la première
réponse c'est d'abord de la compassion à
destination d'abord des familles des
parents de ses enfants qui ont été
victimes d'un drame abominable il y a eu
on l'a vu une nuit de silence on a fait
un rappel au règlement par notre
président automatile de panneaux pour
dire l'émotion qui qui venait sur nos
cœurs pour ma part il y a beaucoup de
sidération dans ce moment-là on a même
du mal à imaginer que un tel drame et
puis se produire c'est-à-dire attaquer
au couteau des enfants donc il y a
vraiment un moment d'émotion il y a du
recueillement et le pays est encore
aujourd'hui au moment où on se parle
sous le choc sous l'émotion de ce drame
qui est absolument abominable sans
prendre des enfants avec un couteau
c'est vraiment il y a quelque chose très
fort qui a écrit l'Assemblée nationale
hier
alors à la droite de la classe politique
certains s'interroge sur le statut de
l'assaillant qui a obtenu à l'asile en
Suède il y a 10 ans il s'est vu refuser
le statut de réfugiés en France 4 jours
avant de passer à l'acte Charles de
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur il
voit d'ailleurs je cite une coïncidence
troublante qu'est-ce que vous en dites
de ces réactions de ces questions qui
sont posées je crois qu'il y a une chose
qui doit s'imposer dans ces moments-là
c'est un délai de décence hier la
première réaction qui aurait dû avoir
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
c'est je le redis des mots de compassion
de recueillement à destination de celles
et ceux qui ont été victimes de cet acte
abominable je regrette que certains se
soient jetés les deux pieds dans des
récupérations dans une
instrumentalisation politique et
notamment la présidente du groupe
parlementaire
qui est allé directement aux quatre
colonnes dire que tout ce qui se passait
à l'Assemblée n'avait plus lieu d'être
et que ce drama devait tout arrêter dans
le pays on voit qu'il y a une volonté
derrière d'instrumentaliser ce qui s'est
passé on a l'habitude de dire parfois
dans ces moments-là que la parole est
d'argent et que le silence vaut d'or
certains aurait mieux fait de se taire
instrumentaliser ne pas surréagir en
tant que responsable politique dans ces
moments on ne doit pas réagir sous le
coup de l'émotion de la colère il faut
prendre le temps du recul attendre que
l'enquête soit faite attendre que les
éléments
quand quelque chose de comme ça comme
vous l'avez dit évidemment que c'est
difficile il y a de l'émotion il y a
aussi de la colère il y a de
l'incompréhension mais nous sommes des
responsables politiques nous
représentants la nation nous avons des
responsabilités nous sommes là aussi
pour ne pas jeter du tumulte dans le
débat pour ne pas souffler sur des
braises qui peuvent être ardentes
malheureusement l'extrême droite l'a
fait et la conséquence c'est qu'on a vu
déjà hier soir des militants
néo-naziques ont défilé dans les
runnaties en criant des slogans à mort
les immigrés voilà les conséquences
d'une récupération ce qui s'est passé
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
quelques heures après le drame
alors on va parler Thomas porte des
retraites vous étiez à l'Assemblée
nationale ce jeudi le texte d'abrogation
de la retraite à 64 ans est alors du
jour une séance commencée sous haute
tension les oppositions accusant la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir privilégié son camp plutôt que
l'institution compte-rendu de séance
avec Marco pommier le règlement rien que
le règlement la Constitution rien que la
Constitution c'est mon rôle et
j'aimerais
que chacun cycle en face de même pivée
applaudi par la majorité hué par la
nupesse cible de la colère des
oppositions la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a déclaré y recevable les
amendements pour annuler la retraite à
64 ans il recevable sur le plan
financier l'opposition dénonce un déni
de démocratie vous abîmer vous
écrabouillez la démocratie parlementaire
et vous surtout il y a une chose que
vous oubliez c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs le émue et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale aux ordres de
l'Elysée assume de ne pas être la
garante des droits du Parlement mais la
misérable courroie de transmission d'un
passage en force ahurissant du côté de
la nuque ou du rassemblement national on
est persuadé que la majorité craint le
vote vous
n'avez assemblé ni dans le peuple
français vous nous avez empêché de voter
vous avez aux éleveurs mais vous êtes
devenus complètement fou un hémicycle
enflammé face aux accusations le
ministre du Travail réplique il dénonce
un coup de communication et le vide de
la proposition de loi du groupe liotte
en arrivant à cette tribune je me pose
une seule question que cherchez-vous que
cherchez-vous en réalité vous souhaitez
uniquement renverser la table et mettre
à mal nos institutions dans un dialogue
de sourd le groupe yote en est réduit à
retirer son texte vidé de sa mesure
phare et donc nous retirons notre projet
de loi consterné par les attaques
directes puissantes contre notre
Parlement un parlement affaibli vive le
Parlement chers collègues vive le
Parlement vive la république et vive la
France avant d'espérer pouvoir tourner
la page des retraites le gouvernement
devra affronter une nouvelle motion de
censure
alors Thomas porte parlons précisément
de cette motion de censure parce que
c'est la fin de partie sur la
proposition de l'iode mais et il y a
cette motion que vous allez porter mais
d'ailleurs pourquoi la porter alors
qu'on sait qu'il y a peu de chance
qu'elle soit adoptée quand on fait des
comptes mais ça c'est vous qui le dites
la dernière fois il a eu 9 voies qui ont
sauvé le gouvernement on n'a pas pu
voter en première lecture à l'Assemblée
on n'a pas pu voter un deuxième lecture
là on est empêché de voter dans le cadre
de la nicheur donc nous on va déposer
une émotion de censure très certainement
aujourd'hui pour qu'elle soit discuter
lundi et chacun devra prendre ses
responsabilités les républicains doivent
prendre leur responsabilité je suis pas
sûr que tous les collègues macronistes
soient très contents de ce qui s'est
tout ce qui s'est passé hier ben
effectivement plusieurs d'entre eux
disent qu'ils sont favorables à
l'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
qu'ils sont conscients qu'il faut un
vote et qu'il faut voter contre cette
réforme ils ont une occasion de le faire
lundi donc il faudra qu'il s'exprime
dans l'ensemble et chacun regardera très
précisément qui va voter cette motion de
tension mais nous on la déposera en tout
cas c'est sûr mais si jamais cette
motion de censure est rejetée est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas un risque au final de
conforter le gouvernement borne et lui
permettre d'aller au-delà des 100 jours
qui avaient été dessiné par Emmanuel
Macron non c'est ce que je viens
d'évoquer c'est-à-dire que cette motion
de censure elle vise aussi à faire voir
celles et ceux qui ont du courage
politique et qui vont jusqu'au bout de
se positionner contre la réforme des
retraites à 64 ans et effectivement les
républicains sont au centre de ce jeu
parce que c'est eux qui peuvent faire la
bascule donc tout le monde regardera
très précisément quel député républicain
votera la motion de censure que nous
allons déposer avec la nippe c'est eux
de prendre la responsabilité pour faire
tomber ce gouvernement le censurer parce
que personne ne veut la référence des
retraites à ce moment vous avez évoqué
la niche haute on va en reparler mais
c'est quand même le fruit de plusieurs
mois de piétinement de la démocratie
d'utilisation de processus un petit
démocratique enfin dans quel monde envie
d'ailleurs les mots du président penché
dit vous êtes devenu fou vous empêcher
les parlementaires de voter voilà ce qui
s'est passé hier pas de vote sur la
retraite à 64 ans mais la Constitution a
été respectée dit le gouvernement est-ce
que pour vous ça pose un problème
démocratique oui ça pose un problème
démocratique parce que quand la
représentation nationale ne peut pas
s'exprimer sur un texte dont le pays ne
veut pas donc des gens sont en grève
depuis des centaines et des dizaines de
jours bon déjà on fait grève partout
dans le pays il faut qu'il y ait une
sortie de crise démocratique comment
voulez-vous que des gens continuent à se
calmer et à aller à l'apaisement comme
le propose d'Emmanuel Macron s'il y a
pas de sortie de crise la sortie de
crise ça peut pas être circuler il y a
rien à voir on continue jusqu'au bout
les gens demandent à ce qu'on puisse
s'exprimer la veille de la niche chiotte
cette Français sur 10 dans un sondage
élab on dit on veut que les
parlementaires s'expriment mais dans
quel pays on vit pour empêcher les
parlementaires de se positionner sur un
sujet aussi central que la réforme des
retraites qui va décaler de deux ans à
l'âge de départ donc il va priver de 2
ans de vie de deux ans de meilleure vie
les Françaises et les Français de ce
pays nous devons pouvoir voter et
s'exprimer sur ce texte alors je dis la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale de
l'assemblée de pardon de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a LeBron Piva était très
critiqué par les oppositions qui lui
reprochent de cette opposé à ce vote sur
l'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans
est-ce qu'elle peut encore présider
cette institution selon vous je crois
qu'elle a montré hier qu'elle était
directement la télégraphie de l'Élysée
et qu'elle prenait ses ordres dans le
bureau d'Emmanuel Macron pour mettre
sous couvert l'Assemblée nationale et
empêcher le vote il y a les bandes
pivetes se comportent pas comme une
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs dès qu'elle préside les
séances il y a des incidents ça se passe
mal elle elle envoie des petites piques
où elle reprend les députés de
l'opposition donc elle se comportent pas
comme une garant de l'institution
pourtant c'est ce qu'elle avait dit dès
le début de sa prise de fonction la vie
je serai la garantie des institutions je
ne suis pas là pour transmettre la
parole du président de la République
mais pour assurer le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas vrai
mais je veux dire un mot parce qu'il y a
les brandes piverts ne la découvre pas
au perchoir il faut se rappeler que sous
la mandature précédente elle était
présidente de la commission des lois
c'est elle qui a enterré la commission
d'affaires sur Alexandre Benalla en 2018
commission d'enquête c'est elle qui en
2019 à empêché l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle commission d'enquête
parlementaire suite aux nouveaux
éléments sur Alexandre Benalla dit quoi
sur elle et c'est elle qui en ce moment
est en train d'empêcher une commission
d'enquête parlementaire que nous
demandons sur le fond Marianne suite aux
révélations concernant la gestion de cet
argent public et notamment le rôle de
Marlène Schiappa donc elle est au
service d'Emmanuel Macron elle est pas
au service du Parlement c'est ça que qui
est très grave et ce qui c'est hier ça a
été dit c'est classéparation des
pouvoirs qui est quand même garant de
nos institutions qui permet la
démocratie de vivre aujourd'hui elle
n'existe plus Emmanuel Macron il peut
pas venir à l'Assemblée mais son point
d'entrée il l'a trouvé avec une
présidente qui aujourd'hui exécute la
voix du monarque présidentiel dans
l'hémicycle alors l'exécutif semble
miser sur l'essoufflement du mouvement
il y a eu la 14e journée de mobilisation
mardi finalement il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de manifestants ce que pour
vous c'est la fin de la mobilisation je
crois pas que c'est la fin de la
mobilisation vous avez évoqué la 14e
journée il y a eu encore du monde dans
la rue il y a encore des gens qui sont
sortis pour dire leur opposition il faut
quand même mesurer qu'on vit une
mobilisation sociale inédite depuis 1968
on a vu des journées d'action depuis le
19 janvier dernier ou déjà on défilé par
million dans la rue déjà on fait grève
10 15 20 jours moi j'ai des gens dans
mon entourage qui ont fait deux mois de
grève qui sont des éboueurs des gens qui
travaillent dans le service public de
l'énergie qui ont des petits salaires et
qui pendant deux mois n'ont pas touché
un euro pour dire qu'ils étaient opposés
à cette réforme donc effectivement il y
a une fatigue et c'est normal quand vous
êtes mobilisés pendant des mois que vous
n'avez plus d'argent
difficile pourtant la colère elle est
toujours prégnante et quand vous faites
des enquêtes d'opinion que vous sondez
les gens sur leur opposition à cette
réforme elle n'a jamais baissé l'opinion
publique ne s'est jamais retournée
contrairement à ce qu'a tenté de faire
Emmanuel Macron en disant oui il y a des
gens qui bloquent le pays ça va
desservir l'intérêt général les gens ils
sont toujours un opposés à la réforme de
solidaire avec les manifestations donc
la colère elle veut pas s'arrêter il y a
une date qui va arriver c'est le 14
juillet vous a pas échappé que c'est la
fin des 100 jours d'apaisement promis
par le Président de la République chez
nous le 14 juillet c'est une date qui
fait écho à un événement qui a marqué le
pays qui la prise de la Bastille je
pense qu'on réserve une surprise à
Emmanuel Macron pour ce jour-là il y
aura certainement une très grande
journée de mobilisation à Paris le 14
juillet pour rappeler que non la page
n'est pas tournée si on prend du recul
sur cette séquence sur la réforme des
retraites Thomas porte est-ce que la
stratégie de la France insoumise a été
la bonne c'est à dire à savoir quand
même mettre de l'agitation dans
l'hémicycle l'exprimer de la colère avec
des propos des images qui parfois ont pu
paraître violents pour certains est-ce
que cette stratégie a été la bonne alors
qu'on voit que finalement dans l'opinion
c'est le rassemblement national qui
récolte les fruits écoutez moi je suis
au coeur des mobilisations quand je
rencontre les habitants de ma
circonscription il me parle pas du
rassemblement national et au contraire
il nous remercie pour le travail qu'on a
fait dans l'hémicycle il nous remercient
pour le fait d'avoir porté leur colère
parfois avec des mots très durs bah
écoutez on nous a fait des leçons
pendant des semaines et des mois sur la
question de la violence on est sur une
réforme qui va abîmer la vie des gens
donc on a traduit la colère populaire
dans l'hémicycle et grâce à notre
mobilisation cette loi elle a pas de
légitimité parlementaire elle n'a pas
été votée elle n'a pas été votée et
celles et ceux qui ont empêché le débats
parce qu'on parlait de la niche haute si
on en est arrivé là c'est parce que la
première fois ça a été déposé dans un
cadre d'un PLFSS ce qui est inédit sur
une réforme budget un budget de la
Sécurité sociale pardon ce qui n'a
jamais été fait donc déjà ils avaient
utilisé un premier artifice avec un
temps de débat contraint donc déjà ils
étaient partis sur une position où ils
ne voulait pas de débat donc nous on a
on a amené le combat d'Al assemblée et
je rappelle que c'est quand même par nos
défenses d'amendement que nous avons
démasqué une des imposteurs de la
réforme qui disait qu'il y avait une
retraite minimale de 1200 euros pour
tout le monde on était parti sur
plusieurs millions puis 5 aujourd'hui on
ne sait plus combien de personnes vont
être concernées donc je crois que nous
avons eu raison de mener la bataille
pour permettre aussi à la mobilisation
sociale de s'organiser et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont fiers et
heureux qu'ils aient eu des
représentants à l'assemblée qui est
imposé cette colère populaire dans les
cycle alors on va fermer la page
retraite en tout cas pour parler de
défense Thomas porte puisque cette
semaine vous avez adopté en tout cas les
députés ont adopté la LPM Laura de
programmation militaire 413 milliards
d'euros pour transformer le modèle de
défense des données aux armées les
moyens de répondre aux nouvelles menaces
après deux semaines de débat et un vote
solennel le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos et voici le résultat
du scrutin
votant 548 exprimé 495 majorité 248 pour
408 contre 87 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
alors Thomas porte l'Assemblée nationale
a adopté mais vous les insoumis vous
avez voté contre cette LPM pourquoi donc
parce que nous étions en désaccord non
pas sur l'augmentation des crédits par
exemple mais sur la question de
l'utilisation et de des objectifs de
cette loi de programmation militaire
puisque c'est pas un petit enjeu vous
avez rappelé les milliards qui vont être
mis sur la table et la question de la
sécurité nationale et de la défense est
une question stratégique nous avons
déposé une compte proposition qui fait
une quarantaine de pages d'ailleurs je
constate que le ministre le corps nu est
arrivé le premier jour des débats avec
notre projet sous le bras pour souligner
son sérieux et je vais en profite aussi
pour féliciter nos camarades Aurélien
Santo les Bastien Lachaud qui étaient
les chefs de fil et qui ont mené un
travail incroyable nous si nous avons
été opposé cette LPM c'est pour
plusieurs raisons il y a évidemment la
question du maintien dans le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN il y a la
question de la dissuasion nucléaire on
ne réfléchit pas à la dissuasion de
demain il y a la question de la
dépendance vis-à-vis des sous-traitants
et des puissances étrangères notamment
sur la livraison des porte-avions
américains il y a la question de la
transition écologique où ça on ne
réfléchit pas après la paix la paix la
paix pétrole pardon donc il y a un
certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels on
était d'accord c'est pour ça que nous
avons voté contre je crois que nous
l'avons plutôt bien exprimé pendant les
15 jours de débat un désaccord sur la
stratégie militaire alors effectivement
vous êtes opposé à des investissements
supplémentaires dans la dissuasion
nucléaire française mais quand on voit
le contexte géopolitique avec Vladimir
Poutine qui mène la guerre sur le sol
européen est-ce que cette dissuasion
nucléaire ce n'est pas une protection
pour l'Europe alors nous ce que nous
avons dit c'est que la dissuasion
nucléaire était un moyen d'assurer la
sécurité des Françaises des Français
s'il n'y avait pas de processus
multilatéral qui permettait d'en sortir
dans tous les pays nous étions pour
rester dans le cadre d'une dissuasion
nucléaire mais nous avons aussi proposé
un commissariat à la dissuasion qui
permettent de réunir des chercheurs des
scientifiques pour réfléchir à la
dissuasion de demain parce que tout le
monde sait très bien que il y a des gens
qui déjà réfléchissent et que dans 30 ou
40 années la dissuasion nucléaire
pourrait être contournée par des
nouveaux éléments donc il faut réfléchir
à comment on construit la dissuasion de
demain y compris avec des armes parfois
moins létales que celle du nucléaire
donc c'est pour ça que nous sommes
opposés à ce qui est fait dans cette LPM
nous sommes pas opposés une forme de
dissuasion et encore une fois je le dis
parce que on a parlé beaucoup de l'OTAN
qui était une des armes qui permettait
d'assurer la sécurité aujourd'hui des
Françaises et des Français ce qui permet
d'assurer la sécurité si la dissuasion
c'est pas le maintien dans l'OTAN ni
dans le commandement intégré donc elle
est pas utile elle est plus utile autant
pour vous déjà il faut rappeler il faut
rappeler que l'OTAN elle aurait dû à
disparaître au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale nous étions opposé au
retour du commandement intégré ce qui a
été fait sous le quinquennat de Nicolas
Sarkozy et quand on interroge celles et
ceux qui étaient les promoteurs du
retour dans la commandement intérêt pour
leur dire mais qu'est-ce que ça a été la
plus-value pour la France d'y revenir
dedans à part quelques postes pour les
officiers ils sont bien incapables de
dire ce que ça a été parce que l'OTAN
est quand même un outil d'influence
américaine au sein de l'Europe et nous
on a fait une proposition très concrète
on a dit qu'il faudrait que le Parlement
se positionne tous les 5 ans pour savoir
si nous devions rester dans le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN Thomas
porte on va maintenant parler de
l'affaire du fond Marianne puisque la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur ce
sujet veille auditionner mercredi
Marlène Schiappa sur ce fonds publics
qu'elle a lancé en tant que ministre en
2021 pour lutter contre la
radicalisation elle est sénateurs
s'interrogent de plus en plus sur son
rôle réel dans le pil de ce fond qui est
suspecté d'avoir été mal utilisé par
certaines associations l'enquête
administrative pointe de graves
dysfonctionnement les explications de
Cécile Sioux
du fond Marianne si l'inspection
générale de l'administration la dédouane
dans son rapport la ministre s'était
facile du processus une fois passé le
lancement officiel d'après les
conclusions son ancien directeur de
cabinet Sébastien Jallet auditionné
mercredi par la commission d'enquête du
Sénat n'est pas aussi catégorique la
ministre serait intervenu pour refuser
l'attribution d'une subvention à une
association SOS Racisme selon les
révélations de Mediapart nous avons sur
cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez ancien donc il y a bien eu sur les
décisions arrêtées en comité sélection
pour l'un de ces lauréat
une affirmation par la ministre c'est
ingérence sème le doute au sein de la
commission d'enquête sur la véritable
implication de la ministre dans cette
affaire comme ministre puisse avoir
veut dire sur des propositions de
subventions qui sont faites par un
problème c'est pas le sujet en soi ce
qui est le sujet c'est que Marine japa a
toujours dit qu'elle n'avait pas
participé à ce choix voilà donc là il y
a une contradiction est-ce que entre ce
qu'elle a toujours dit et la réalité les
membres de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat espère faire toute la lumière sur
ses contradictions lors de l'audition de
la ministre la semaine prochaine les
mécanismes de décision le choix tout ça
n'est pas clair il y a il y a pour le
moins de la porosité entre
l'administration et le politique donc on
va recouper les différentes auditions
les déclarations les témoignages dont je
rappelle qu'ils sont fait sous serment
et que donc ils engagent la parole de
chacune de chacun des personnes
auditionnées les sénateurs écouteront
certainement d'une autre oreille
l'audition de Christian Gravel le
gestionnaire de la subvention accablé
par le rapport de l'Inspection générale
de l'administration il a démissionné
mercredi il avait pourtant défend u
devant la commission le travail de ses
équipes ne l'a pas été Thomas apporte
selon vous cette affaire du fond
Marianne c'est une affaire politique ou
c'est un fiasco administratif c'est une
affaire politique et on voit bien la
stratégie qui est utilisée c'est celle
du fusible c'est à dire de faire sauter
là le préfet qui a démissionné qui était
en charge de la gestion de l'argent qui
avait été récolté et de l'attribution
des subventions mais il y avait une
responsabilité politique du ministère
celle qui est en charge du ministère
c'est Marlène Chapat donc il y a une
responsabilité politique c'est elle je
vois d'ailleurs que le dernier élément
livré par l'enquête de Mediapart dit que
la ministre est intervenue directement
dans le dossier pour faire en sorte que
SOS racisme n'est pas à 100000 euros de
subventions parce qu'elle avait un
désaccord politique avec le président de
ce racisme qui aurait pris des positions
contre le gouvernement donc la ministre
est intervenue directement dans un
dossier pour empêcher une association
d'avoir une subvention ce qui est quand
même pose un problème sérieux est-ce que
pour vous Marianne ça peut être en
position confortable pour rester au
gouvernement je crois que Marlène
Schiappa devrait tirer les leçons de ce
qui s'est passé et devrait quitter le
gouvernement ça fait longtemps qu'elle
aurait dû le quitter mais cette affaire
révèle encore une fois
une énorme histoire de copinage au sein
de la Major des présidentielle parce
qu'on parle quand même d'un fond qui a
été créé au lendemain de l'assassinat
horrible de Samuel Paty qui était censé
diffuser du contenu pour lutter contre
le séparatisme en ligne à destination
des jeunes publics et qui au final quand
on regarde ce que dit le rapport qui a
été fait des inspection il y a une des
associations qui a touché 300000 € ils
sont incapables de dire ce qu'ils ont
fait de l'argent il y a eu 11
abonnements téléphoniques pour trois
personnes qui travaillaient ils ont loué
des bureaux l'avenue Montaigne on sait
pas pourquoi une autre association elle
a publié 47 vidéos ou dans les vidéos il
y a des attaques abdominales contre les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
qui sont présentés contre Emmanuel
Macron donc on a utilisé de l'argent
public pour financer des gens qui
menaient des campagnes au service du
président de la République donc oui
c'est un scandale d'État c'est un
scandale politique et je le redis ici il
faut qu'il y a les bandes pivées la
présidente de l'Assemblée autorise le
Parlement avant une commission d'enquête
comme c'est fait au Sénat nous devons
faire la lumière sur ce qui s'est passé
avec le fond Marianne et pour l'instant
c'est pas possible cette commission
d'enquête à l'Assemblée
joue son rôle de gardien du temple
d'Emmanuel Macron elle protège Marlène
Schiappa elle interdit aujourd'hui
d'avoir une commission d'enquête
parlementaire vous visez Marlène
Schiappa mais finalement elle n'est pas
la mise en cause dans le rapport
administratif qui pointe notamment et
bien les dysfonctionnements de la
gestion de l'administration elle n'est
pas mise en examen est-ce qu'elle a
vraiment cette responsabilité écoutez il
y a quand même plusieurs éléments je
viens de l'évoquer la question de
l'intervention directe sur la subvention
à une association le l'ancien préfet qui
dit qu'il fallait plus de temps pour
attribuer l'argent et le cabinet de la
ministre est intervenu pour dire il faut
aller plus vite mais si on demande aussi
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
c'est pour permettre de faire la lumière
parce que on peut pas croire qu'un fort
ministériel qui soit créé doté de 2
millions d'euros et qui est pas derrière
une gestion politique du dossier c'est
pas une simple question administrative
ce qui a été fait par le ministère de
marine chappa c'est une question
politique et le ou la responsabilité
était celui ou celle qui était en tête
du ministère et c'est Marlène chappa
mais qui comment sous quelle forme
pourrait prendre cette initiative de
commission d'enquête à l'Assemblée
puisque les groupes de l'opposition à
droite tirage et vous vous avez utilisé
le vote sur uberface comment ça pourrait
prendre il y a pas les commissions
d'enquête elles sont pas uniquement
ouvertes sur droite tirage c'est-à-dire
que la présidente de l'Assemblée elle
j'ai décidé que une commission d'enquête
une demande est recevable en dehors du
droit de tirage c'est tout à fait de
l'Assemblée nationale bien sûr pour
faire la lumière sur ce qui s'est passé
il y a les bandes privées à le pouvoir
de faire ça sauf qu'aujourd'hui force de
constater que comme ce qu'elle a fait
hier dans le cadre de la niche haute
elle se met en première ligne pour
protéger Emmanuel Macron et pour
protéger le pouvoir vous parler de
copinage mais Marine Chapa vous a déjà
répondu notamment aux insoumis c'était
sur ce plateau elle le dit elle n'a
aucun lien avec les dirigeants de ces
associations de ces associations elle a
peut-être aucun lien avec les dirigeants
de ces associations ça c'est la
commission d'enquête qui permettra aussi
de le dire mais au final et il est quand
même intervenu pour empêcher qu'une
association et de l'argent et d'autres
argent ont été donnés à des associations
dont on ne sait pas ce qu'il y a été
fait avec cet argent là donc ça pose un
sujet et c'est pas le préfet qui est en
charge du fond ministériel qui prenait
les décisions il y a un arbitrage
politique derrière je ne peux pas croire
une seconde que Marlène Chapman n'est
pas eu un regard sur l'argent de ce fond
qui a été utilisé et distribué des
associations parce qu'elle n'avait fait
une opération politique de communication
faut se souvenir elle faisait le tour de
tous les plateaux télé pour appeler à
donner de l'argent pour dire qu'il y
avait une urgence avec la question
séparatiste dans ce pays donc derrière
c'est un dossier politique et la
responsable politique c'est Marine Chapa
encore une fois mais ce qui est
nécessaire de vouloir mettre en place
toujours ses fonds est-ce que c'est
utile pour vous ce genre d'initiative ou
c'est que de la communication force de
constater que c'est de la communication
et en plus de la communication qui a
servi à des associations qui ont touché
de l'argent public et qui n'ont rien
fait parce qu'à tous ces gens qui nous
font des leçons de bonne conduite des
leçons de gestion d'argent public des
leçons de bonne tenue on voit que là on
est quand même sur une affaire où on a
utilisé instrumentalisé l'assassinat
d'un professeur Samuel Paty pour créer
un fond récolter de l'argent donner à
des associations interdire à d'autres
d'y avoir accès et ça m'a servi à rien
donc ce fond là il a à la fois été
scandaleux sur le fond c'est à dire
qu'il est instrumentalisé la mort de
quelqu'un et de l'argent public a été
dilapidé alors qu'on aurait pu
l'utiliser ailleurs et je termine en
disant un mot la famille de Samuel Paty
elle-même s'est dit 13h et par les
révélations de Marianne de Mediapart et
par les artistes de presse qui commence
à sortir et qui voit que finalement ben
on a utilisé la mort d'un professeur
pour une opération politique tout va
porter on va regarder l'agenda la
semaine prochaine à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat
[Musique]
et justement l'agenda du Sénat sera
marqué par des auditions importantes de
la commission d'enquête sur le fond
mariage mardi à 9h les sénateurs
entendront Mohamed cifaoui essayiste et
dirigeant de l'Union des sociétés
d'éducation physique et de préparation
militaire une association justement mise
en cause dans cette affaire mercredi à
10h marine Chapat sera auditionné par la
commission d'enquête c'est elle qui on
le rappelle à lancer ce fond lorsqu'elle
était ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté et puis mercredi à 16h30 ce
sera autour de Sonia bakes l'actuel
ministre de la Citoyenneté de répondre
aux questions des sénateurs des
auditions vous pourrez suivre et bien
sur Public Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale bien évidemment la motion de
censure attendue en début de semaine à
partir de lundi les députés examineront
aussi une proposition de loi pour mieux
répartir l'offre de soins sur le
territoire et donc lutter contre les
déserts médicaux à suivre mercredi
Eric Dupont Moretti qui sera auditionné
sur le projet de loi d'orientation pour
la justice qui est en discussion au
Sénat et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup Thomas d'avoir été notre
invité cette semaine et merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine ciao ciao
[Musique]